schneiden sie sich besser an denn es
erwarten sie haar sträubende aufnahmen
ob reingefahren oder platt gemacht
haarscharf vorbei oder mittenrein
kleine kameras auf dem armaturenbrett
sogenannte des camps zeichnen gnadenlos
alles auf
in vielen ländern boomt der markt für
des camps die aufnahmen sollen bei
unfällen als beweismittel dienen und vor
betrügern schützen die abkassieren
wollen
kein wunder also dass immer mehr
verblüffende videoclips im umlauf sind
halten sie sich gut fest wir starten
unsere reise um die welt mit bildern die
ihnen garantiert den atem rauben werden
los geht's
das sind die spektakulärsten des camps
und keine sorge
niemand wird hier ernsthaft verletzt
auch wenn es manchmal knapp wird
richtig knapp
heute mit dabei straßen die zu flüssen
werden
falsche entscheidungen in letzter
sekunde
ein tiger mit einer vorliebe für
stoßstangen und viel lärm um nichts
vorsicht ungesicherte ladung
wenn es darum geht sperre gefragt von a
nach b zu bringen werden viele
verkehrsteilnehmer äußerst erfinderisch
doch wer sich zu viel auflädt läuft
gefahr die kontrolle über sein fahrzeug
zu verlieren
dann reichen ein bisschen seitenwind
oder eine zu scharf genommene kurve aus
um ins schlingern zu kommen
[Musik]
so ergeht es diesem lkw voller
backsteine
der fahrer des autos neben ihm wird
unter einer lawine aus baumaterial
begraben
zum glück kommt er unverletzt davon ob
seine versicherung wohl für diese art
von steinschlag haftet
[Musik]
nächster fall ähnliches problem
beim zweiten lastwagen wurden die
betonpfähle auf der ladefläche nicht
ausreichend gesichert das ergebnis sieht
nach einem tragischen unfall aus
kaum zu glauben aber niemand wird
verletzt der mopedfahrer entgeht
haarscharf einer kollision die pfeile
schießen durch die kabine und verfehlen
den fahrer nur um zentimeter
kennen sie das spiel mikado die regeln
sind einfach erst die stäbe fallen
lassen
[Musik]
und sie dann stück für stück aufheben
das dürfte bei der menge holz eine weile
dauern
bei anspruchsvollen transporten lässt
man lieber einen profi ran und macht es
auf keinen fall so wie diese jungs
und hier ein anwärter fürs guinness-buch
der rekorde
wie viele rohre kann ein einzelner
mensch auf einem moped sicher
transportieren
[Musik]
was für ein gefährt sich unter diesem
haufen verbirgt lässt sich nur erahnen
immerhin falls es brenzlig werden sollte
hat der fahrer seinen persönlichen
riesen airbag gleicht dabei
genau wie diese beiden herren
[Musik]
jetzt bloß nicht umkippen
alle in die rettungsboote die flut kommt
jedes jahr haben millionen von menschen
mit überschwemmungen zu kämpfen
wenn der himmel alle schleusen öffnet
verwandeln sich straßen in reißende
flüsse
und ohne amphibienfahrzeug wird man ganz
schnell weg gespült
diese teneriffa urlauber bewundern die
eindrucksvollen wasserfälle der insel
moment mal hier ist normalerweise da
kein fluss
strömende regenfälle haben aus dieser
küstenstraße ein flussbett gemacht und
das wasser spült jede menge geröll auf
die fahrbahn
wer es mit seinem wagen über stock und
stein schafft läuft am ende gefahr auf
einer einsamen insel zu stranden
fährt der noch oder schwimmt er schon
seelenruhig tuckert der fahrer mit
seinem laster durch das hochwasser
[Musik]
ja
solange es gut geht
auf dem parkplatz herrscht land unter
jetzt sind kreative lösungen gefragt um
trockenen fußes zum auto zu gelangen
dieser mann will auf einem einkaufswagen
zu seinem wagen schärfen
das funktioniert allerdings mehr
schlecht als recht
[Musik]
doch es naht schon zwei unerschrockene
helfer
[Musik]
wenn sturzbäche die straße runter
rauschen machen sich selbst mülleimer
auf zu neuen ufern
die straße runter bis zur nächsten
kreuzung und noch viel weiter
wenn das leben einem überschwemmte
straßen schenkt warum nicht eine
kanutour machen
schwierig wird es allerdings wenn das
wasser gerade einmal knöchelhoch steht
[Musik]
na geht doch
hoffentlich bremst der auch für
kanufahrer
[Musik]
adrenalinjunkies nutzen die
wildwasserbahn vor der haustür für eine
server einlage
dieser junge mann leitet im schlepptau
eines bullis durch die nachbarschaft und
zeigt ein paar lässige tricks
[Musik]
bis in die brandung vom brett fliegt
jetzt kracht
[Musik]
schon kleine fehler können schwere
unfälle verursachen ob misslungenen
überholmanöver nicht gesetzten blinker
oder einfach zu viel tempo wer
leichtsinnig fährt bringt sich selbst
und andere in gefahr also immer schön an
die verkehrsregeln halten
hier ein beispiel für unachtsames fahren
wollte die fahrerin überholen oder war
sie gerade mit dem autoradio beschäftigt
der zusammenprall hätte tödlich enden
können
doch in diesem fall hat es nur die autos
schwer erwischt
ist das die richtige ausfahrt ja ganz
sicher
die fahrerin ist zum glück angeschnallt
und kommt mit leichten verletzungen
davon
kaum zu glauben bei diesen aufnahmen
[Musik]
ein schöner tag für eine spazierfahrt
jetzt noch schnell den lieferwagen
überholen
und dann ab in den raum
diese motorradfahrer lassen auf der
straße so richtig die sau raus sie rasen
sie schlängeln sich durch den verkehr
und sie fahren riskante überholmanöver
bis das passiert
[Musik]
die stimmung scheint angespannt zu sein
so schnell fliegt man aus einer
motorradgang
[Musik]
zu niedriger reifendruck ist eine der
häufigsten unfallursachen
bei zu hohem tempo knallt er ist der
reifen
dann kracht die leitplanke
und auto shepherd gegen auto
bevor man auf der autobahn die spur
wechselt sollte man sich umsehen der
schatten des lkw lässt erahnen was
gleich passiert
ein blick in den spiegel hätte das
verhindern können
[Musik]
dieser kelch 1 eilig zu haben
das lenkrad vibriert regelrecht
mit über 120 in die kurve
keine gute idee
der wagen kommt ins schleudern und
überschlägt sich
jetzt begegnungen der pelzigen 8
der zoo ist ein toller ort um tiere aus
nächster nähe zu bestaunen
wenn es der zufall will begegnen einem
auch im alltag ein paar pelzigen freunde
so wie dieser kleine spaziergänge
[Musik]
aber nicht alle sind so umgänglich
dieser kalifornische bär hat keine scheu
vor menschen oder ihren autos der weist
im griff
offenbar kennt er sich bestens aus mit
fahrzeugen
nun führt zu den leuten
der bursche ist ganz schön gewieft und
weiß wie man eine autotür öffnet
gerade noch rechtzeitig bemerkt der
fahrer den eindringling und gibt gas
keine türen aufmachen
der bär bleibt verdutzt zurück aber das
steht ja noch das auto des kameramanns
[Musik]
man könnte meinen dieser kleine kerl
versucht sich als tramper auf zwei
beinen sucht er nach einer passenden
mitfahrgelegenheit
dieser fahrer nimmt anscheinend keine
anhalter mit
[Musik]
weitaus eindrucksvoller ist da ein
ausgewachsener tiger der offenbar
anspruch auf diese straße erhebt
bevor er die autos weiter fahren lässt
sichert er sich eine stoßstange als
trophäe zuerst könig des dschungels und
jetzt auch könig der straße
[Musik]
und noch eine raubkatze auf tour hat
jemand im löwenmännchen die vorfahrt
genommen es wird sauer
[Applaus]
zwei löwen flößen einem gleich doppelt
so viel respekt ein die majestätischen
tiere flanieren seelenruhig zwischen den
autos entlang also türen verriegeln und
hoffen dass sie keinen hunger haben
[Musik]
nicht jede begegnung mit einem
vierbeiner lässt einem das herz bis zum
hals schlagen
der motorradfahrer bremste nicht nur für
das kleine kätzchen er bringt es sogar
höchstpersönlich aus der gefahrenzone
das gibt karma punkte
koala bären sind einfach süß
dieser hier hatte sich mitten auf der
straße bequem gemacht
ihm scheint die fahrbahnmarkierung zu
schmecken ob das lösungsmittel drin sind
mit ein wenig hilfe findet er den weg
zurück ins grüne
[Musik]
schluss mit süß jetzt gibt es ärger
streitereien im straßenverkehr gibt es
überall auf der welt aber ein land ist
ganz klar die nummer eins
in großbritannien gibt es die meisten
auseinandersetzungen
die einen sind schockierend
[Musik]
und viele sind einfach nur zum lachen
dieser möchtegern polizist ist auf
seiner morgendlichen streife unterwegs
da fällt ihm eine frau auf die am steuer
genüsslich ihr müsli löffelt prompt
stellt er sie zur rede
sie auf damit ich habe ihr nummernschild
aufgenommen doch nicht wahr sein
frühstücken ist wichtig aber so das ist
gefährlich die frühstück im auto
und keinen interessiert oder sie
vielleicht wie ist müsli alles klar
keine cerealien am steuer
zwischen autofahrern und bikern kommt es
immer wieder zu reibereien
dieser fahrer ist schon auf 180
und er wird immer wütender
am ende lässt er dann so richtig dampf
ab
der motorradfahrer behält die nerven
statt fahrer gegen fahrer heißt es
manchmal auch mensch gegen maschine
[Musik]
dieser rollerfahrer hat sich offenbar
eine echte gurke andrehen lassen
[Musik]
da geht nichts mehr
vielleicht hilft ja ein bisschen rütteln
oder ein beherzter tritt
sieht nicht so aus
willkommen in schottland heimat der
sturen hochlandrinder
schwer zu sagen worum es hier geht der
kerl hat jedenfalls einen ordentlichen
wutanfall und scheint dabei zu vergessen
dass der motorradfahrer einen schutzhelm
trägt
sie praktisch
[Musik]
im nahkampf hat er dadurch einen
entscheidenden vorteil
zum glück bringt ein passant die beiden
streithähne zur vernunft
[Musik]
diese briten räumen ihre
meinungsverschiedenheit in einem
kultivierten gespräch aus der welt
da können sie so viele fotos machen wie
sie wollen es ist ein video ja
meinetwegen ich fahre nicht zur seite
ich bin ja schon oft durch gefahren
er fährt hier öfter durch klar
zwei autos kommen leicht aneinander
vorbei und uwe sauer und mir darf man
nicht umdrehen sie hätten ja gar nicht
reinfahren sollen sie haben mich doch
gesehen aber zu spät von wegen zwar ohne
tee und gebäck aber äußerst zivilisiert
von mir aus bleiben wie er den ganzen
tag ich bin genauso hartnäckig wie sie
eine klassische pattsituation
london eine pulsierende metropole hier
ist man nie zu alt für eine ordentliche
rangelei
dieser rüstige herr wird plötzlich zum
berserker und zieht dem radfahrer und
seinem kumpel 1 mit dessen fahrrad über
[Musik]
das hat gesessen
und nun ein leuchtendes beispiel wie man
brenzlige situationen am besten löst
manchmal kann ein beinahe unfall zu
einem riesenstreit werden
im ersten augenblick sieht es hier auch
ganz danach aus
weil es gut tut mir leid keine sorge
nichts passiert
wir haben super reagiert der
motorradfahrer versichert sich dass es
der dame gut geht menschen machen fehler
verständnis und vergebung machen die
welt zu einem glücklicheren ort
bitte recht freundlich
zum abschluss noch ein paar highlights
aus dem kuriositätenkabinett was für
eine verrückte welt
[Musik]
also fahren sie bitte immer vorsichtig
ob mit oder ohne des camp
[Musik]
o